[Music]
I'm reto Meier and I'm Stephanie wands
joining us now ray wank security product
manager for Google cloud thanks so much
for joining us thank you it's great to
be here so security is such a vital part
of everything we do online and in the
cloud let's talk about security at scale
as our environments grow larger security
simply must keep up how is network
security changing as we move from brutal
environments built on static IPS to
micro services yeah the traditional IP
based networking policies required to
have very detailed knowledge on the
nitty gritty can parts of your
networking configurations they don't
really offer your concept of which
service can talk to what unless you know
you segregate them by IP addresses and
subnets ahead of time and this quickly
becomes unwieldy right as you scale your
infrastructure especially as you
introduce the concept of micro services
and this is where a cloud native
platform like a steel or dementia
version CSM give a very different kind
of experience they allow the admins to
define high-level policies that focus on
application requirements our business
logic the micro services are backed by
namespaces which give you natural
isolation boundaries and each service is
is also given a unique history of
service identity then you can step
policies leveraging these identities and
boundaries for example you can set it to
be zero trust by default between the
services so that any communication will
require explicit policies and then
mutual TLS is enforced by default and
once you have configured policies CSM
can allow you to centrally manage and
monitor and control service to service
traffic and alert or any policy
violation so this is how you know where
the micro service focused a platform
like CSM it's much simpler to to both
create and do ongoing monitoring of your
network security policies so how does
moving into a hybrid cloud environment
impact security yeah so moving to hybrid
environment especially with protocol
anthos right means note you now have a
consistent control playing between
on-prem and cloud it gives you a single
atom experience in a single pane of
glass which makes a much simpler to have
central visibility and control across a
hybrid deployments and then you can also
start using some of the Google security
abilities even for young prime workloads
for example products like binary
authorization or and those config
management now work for on-prem as well
and of course another benefit of using
hybrid platform is that helps your work
clothes to get clout ready
right because containers are a portable
and yamming spirits the same so when it
comes to time to migrate it's a very
straightforward process and of course
once your workloads migrated to cloud we
offer you additional security values
things like shielded VMs or zero
downtime patching through live migration
even when there are really big you know
hardware round or abilities like specter
and meltdown
you mentioned security consistency what
are some of the best practices to ensure
a security baseline with consistency and
reproducibility for all of your
resources in the cloud great question we
know that security is kind of shared
responsibility right we do our part and
customers do their parts so in a
platform we offer a lot of security
capability so that customers can start
on a much higher baseline by the same
time we also make sure that you also
want to make sure your your part of
responsibility becomes easy as well and
that's often down through you know
templatized departments central config
and policy management and ongoing
monitoring and learning so then in terms
of deployments by using kubernetes style
api you can express your configurations
as decorator templates then entos config
management give you a central source of
truth for these templates and allow you
to deploy the config and policy updates
by get-ups and crc deepest patches these
changes then get deploy to across all of
your clusters and measures in
environment to ensure consistency and
when it comes to constraints the couple
of frameworks they keep her policy
controller and facility config malla
daters that we are actually developing
any open source with with communities
they allow admins to standardize
configurations across your entire
organization you can for example set
guardrails buy presubmit checks in your
release pipeline so that miss
configuration can't even get into the
deployment process and then in case you
know drift happened in production you
can also set alerts so they know
for monitoring we also have cloud asset
inventory and cloud security command
center they give you a central view of
the state of all of your resources in
production and then can alter your
changes and risks and security findings
and so on so together these tools help
you through the lifecycle of managing
your security config settings it's
fantastic can you talk a little bit
about declarative configs to make
security controls consistent across yeah
so we all know one of the most costly
mistakes and admin can make is this
configuration right it's almost fairly
easy to accidentally set your I am
controls to be to be public or you know
make your network configuration to be
true way too permissive and when you do
that you open up your sensitive resource
to two attacks and data leaks so this is
where you know the critical if it makes
a difference because it helps the admin
to focus on the end of the end state and
then allow you to offload the
intermediate orchestration and workflows
and keeping up consistencies really to
the platform and then when we do that
across a lot of resources across many
clusters and meshes we basically achieve
reproducibility and recovery from drift
and and therefore they reduce the
complexity of applying security controls
and they also make it much easier to
share security best practices because
you can you can deploy template I
solutions and not only is it important
to declare your security configs across
your environments but also monitor
inevitable risks so we have a big launch
as you mentioned cloud security command
center how do we help customers get
visibility into risk in their
environments yeah we're very excited
about cloud security command center
because it kind of unifies the security
detections from Google right together
with a lot of the key third-party
detections for the main essential place
and really help the admins to to view
them analyze them and take actions in
place for example one of the
capabilities is security security health
analytics right scans and detects over
20 common vulnerabilities from publicly
exposed storage buckets - we talked
about you know very permissive our rules
to misconfigure kubernetes custer's and
so on
in a similarly you have anomaly
detection it automatically detects some
of the key threats from you know crypto
jacking to expose service come
credentials to outbound DDoS and then
with this GA release another benefit you
get is now cloud SCC unified security
findings from a variety of Google cloud
products from events threat detection to
binary authorization to cloud asset
inventory to XT and and so on how you
can use it well if you're in a pressed
company Ryan you have a finance
department for example that stores
credit card inflammation assess your
personal data you can use cloud SCC to
scan the infrastructure used for storing
the system information identifying
vulnerabilities as well as finding
active threats that are targeting these
vulnerabilities and that's a lot of
funny so we give you a way to manage and
organize these findings by attaching
business context to the findings and the
resources by our code security marks and
then we all know that getting the data
is the first step right what you really
want to do is to improve your security
posture from our data so cloud SCC also
allows you to actually respond to take
actions by for example triggering alerts
are creating irm incidents or directly
executing and remediation operations by
cloud functions great thanks ray your
insights into security will continue to
be vital to any company that wants to
build and grow quickly thank you
[Music]
you